a trivia question best special jobs of
all time
adam vinitari's great great grandfather
served under this ill-fated general
what is the general's name
ill-fated general
great great grandfather
god ill-fated i know it did not end well
um gosh i have no idea i feel like i
have names coming this general had no
patches on his uniform either no
all right just tell me who it is who the
hell is it i assume it's custer is it
custer
okay general custer see i i i i had
names going in my head but i was like i
actually was a little scared that sounds
too stupid there so i wasn't sure
well you did a good job thanks uh oh
well there he is
awesome hair he's got the trevor
lawrence hair with a little curl in it
that's what lawrence would look like if
he uh you know if he if he put curlers
in his hair before he went to bed at
night that's what he looked like the
next morning all right uh let's take a
break not take a break let's get the
first pick the hell is your takeaway or
taking a break
it's you know we got nine minutes left
in the show we got a lot a lot to do and
not a lot of time to do it in uh i'll go
with
best special teamer of all time i'll go
with devin hester
best return man of all time um
a weapon from from really anywhere on
the field i feel bad that he never
really developed as a receiver the way
that he could have you got to find a way
to just get the ball in the guy's hands
and let him go right but i think devin
hester
for for what he did in the return game
and he will be in the hall of fame
should be in the hall of fame i don't
have a vote but i'd like to think the
people who do recognize he should get
into the hall of fame so i'll go devin
hester yeah i i hear you there i that
probably would have it was in the
running for my first pick for sure
honestly good note about devin hester
too check out his little boy on
instagram playing football it's kind of
funny he's like this little small kid
with a giant head it's like a big bobble
head and he makes everybody miss and
breaks their ankles that's kind of funny
but devin hester yes i'm with you there
all right well i mean geez i'll go adam
vinatieri i mean i mean yeah one of the
greatest special teams players of all
time and clutch moments i think that's
all i can really say i mean he helps the
greatest franchise we've seen in
football over the last 20 years he
helped them win a lot of super bowls
helped the colts too so he's just uh i
mean i know this is the adam vinitarian
memorial draft but as far as clutch
kickers are concerned or kickers you
trust to come through in the clutch adam
veneteri i think is at the top of the
list in the all-time category as far as
that's concerned so i will take him
and that really is one of the all-time
great moments in league history that's
amazing the forced overtime after the
tuck rule
allowed the patriots to continue to
pursue the overtime and obviously they
want it in overtime i'll go uh ray guy
next because ray guy was like the
punters punter ray guy was the guy who
just bombed it everywhere and i remember
when they did the pro bowl when they
first built the superdome and the
scoreboard hung over the field oh right
he hit he hit the thing
he hit it i think multiple times in the
pro bowl so the guy just had a cannon
and he finally got into the to the hall
of fame which was long overdue but well
deserved but but ray guy was you know
that there were a few punter or kicker
names that kind of struck fear in your
heart in the 70s ray guy did ray got
you're right
you know
i mean i know ray guy just you know from
my younger years it's one of those guys
like one of those punters where it just
looked different and it sounded
different when the ball went off his
foot it's a lot like actually a guy who
i've thought about taking here i don't
know if i'm going to get it to but like
shane leckler remember that punter for
the the raiders too it's a weapon it was
like oh they got the ball at midfield
well they're gonna punt it and you're
getting it inside the five there's like
a magnet with the ball in the inside the
five yard line with the way they did it
so good one by you uh i i like that a
lot all right so
i'm stuck here and i'm not sure which
one i wanted to go with here oh okay um
i'm gonna go with a guy from my
childhood the really the first special
teamer that
i saw
like
be a real thing and that's bill bates of
the dallas cowboys like when i was
growing up in the 80s and my dad had to
play the dallas cowboys it seemed like
every time the cowboys punted bill bates
was the one down there making the tackle
whether it was you know dave megan or
whoever he was making the tackle so he's
the first guy i knew of that and of
course he is one of the greatest of all
time played on all special teams and was
just like a heat-seeking missile as far
as a tackler on kickoff punt whatever it
may be but he was really the first guy i
knew in that manner
i guess i'll see your bill bates and
reggia steve tasker if you're going to
leave him on the board yeah we've got
we've got to put him on there no doubt i
really thought about reggie roby though
because roby
showed up early to mid 80s and he had
this release and it was like the ball
exploded off of his foot when he would
he held it differently than other
punters did but that when that ball hit
it just it was like it was shot out of a
rifle right going the other way but i'll
go steve tasker as my
i'm with you there i would have taken
him next uh if you didn't taskers yeah
again watching him with the buffalo
bills it just seemed like you know the
ball
and the time the returner was going to
catch the ball we're always going to
meet with steve tasker being there
simultaneously i mean it just seems like
it it worked that way um okay my last
one i'm going to go with josh cribbs the
old cleveland browns football wow yeah
wow this cribs to me is unique in this
aspect he was a great returner
but
unlike a lot of other great returners he
was also a great go down the field and
make the tackle type of guy that's
that's rare usually like to go down the
field to make the tackle kind of guy
that's just what he does and then he
blocks for the returners and that this
guy was a great returner yet one of the
best you know pursuers of the football
they had on special teams i think that's
really rare i'm going to give josh
cribbs uh some love there
you know that's how cordaro patterson
kind of exactly
for his career you know he he's
obviously a great returner but he he
became in his fourth year with the
vikings a gunner i don't think he does
that anymore but uh was very good at it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports